while Robert I'll be SOR you talked a
little bit after Game five about the
mental aspect of coming back from an
injury we just found out that that Kevin
Durant did I'm indeed ruptured his
Achilles and he was speaking about that
can you just expand a little bit about
the mental part of you know dealing with
a serious injury and what piece of
advice would you like to give to Kevin
Durant as he goes through that journey
just from my own experience you know
just good talk from you know what I've
been through you know like I said you
just you know we worked so hard to get
to this point in you know the games just
taken away from you especially with leg
injuries and things like that you're not
really able to run or do anything you
know on the floor so you really just
have to change your mindset on things
and you know try to attack each day of
getting better and you know just just
know that you're gonna play again one
day and you want to come back as you
know the player that you were you were
and you know make sure you come up when
you feel healthy you feel good enough
that she does she feel confident enough
in yourself to you know go back out
there on the floor
and know that that day will come and
just like I said attack each day you
know that's that's that's your
assignment to get back to what the thing
that you love to do